la pandemia acabó con la débil
recuperación económica el banco mundial
rebajó su pronóstico de crecimiento
mundial a causa de los continuos brotes
de kobe 19 el organismo advirtió que la
demanda de los consumidores que había
crecido por los confinamientos se
disipará al igual que los apoyos
fiscales que varias economías sostenían
cuando llegó la pandemia hobbits tv2
covite sigue entre nosotros estamos
experimentando una ola de omicron los
niveles de deuda son bastante altos
tenemos presiones inflacionistas tenemos
retos relacionados con el clima cuando
esto se junta en un espacio político muy
limitado para las economías de los
mercados emergentes estos riesgos
aumentan la posibilidad de un aterrizaje
brusco
en el caso de américa latina el banco
mundial proyecta un crecimiento de
apenas el 26 por ciento en 2022 y 2,7
por ciento para 2023 mientras que el
crecimiento mundial también muestra una
clara desaceleración
de cara al futuro proyectamos una
pronunciada desaceleración y las cifras
son claras
[Música]
la economía mundial creció un 5 y medio
por ciento pero de cara a este año
veremos un crecimiento en torno al 4% y
el año siguiente la cifra baja al 3% se
expresa pero no solo omicron amenaza a
la economía el foro económico mundial
publicó un informe donde destaca los
principales riesgos para la humanidad en
los próximos años entre los que figuran
la crisis climática la desigualdad que
se disparó con la pandemia en economías
emergentes la pérdida de empleos la
ciberseguridad la salud mental la deuda
pública y nuevas enfermedades
infecciosas